en france 24 hablamos de economía y para
eso nos acompaña jorge hurtado nuestro
periodista especializado jorge
bienvenido y empecemos hablando de
shanghai porque el aislamiento ante el
nuevo brote está teniendo consecuencias
en la economía de qué se trata así es
bueno esta ciudad de 26 millones de
habitantes inició un confinamiento
escalonado que va a terminar hasta el
próximo 5 de abril y del cual desde ya
se hacen las preguntas de cuál va a ser
el impacto económico que va a tener no
sólo en china haciendo en el mundo
también se espera un impacto en la
economía china como el internacional por
su estatus de centro financiero y
logístico varios reportes en redes
sociales mostraban largas filas a la
entrada de supermercados y están entre
pasivos por compras de pánico el
distrito financiero de pudong de
shanghai y las zonas cercanas estarán
bloqueadas desde este lunes hasta el
viernes mientras se realizan pruebas
masivas según comunicó el gobierno local
varias empresas se verán afectadas por
este cierre entre ellas tecla que
suspendió su producción al menos un día
a medida que el gobierno local
intensifica estas restricciones
disneyland de shanghái se encuentra
entre los negocios que también han
cerrado varios economistas afirman que y
el sector industrial de la ciudad poder
resistir esta interrupción pero otros
han ido rebajando las previsiones de
crecimiento de china a medida que los
brotes siguen extendiéndose según nomura
holdings la economía china se enfrenta a
su peor presión a la baja desde que
comenzó la pandemia del cobat y sin
haber jorge y el g7 que calificó de
inaceptable pagar suministros a rusia en
rublos así es inclusive los ministros le
pidieron a las empresas que rechacen
esta petición del presidente ruso
vladimir putin que anunció que los
suministros de gas y de otras fuentes de
energía sean pagados en rublos esto como
respuesta a las sanciones de occidente
pero según robert sabe quién es ministro
de economía de alemania todos los
ministros coincidieron en que exigir el
pago en rublos constituye una violación
de los contratos vigentes alemania es
uno de los países más reacios a incluir
el sector energético en las sanciones
contra rusia esto porque el 55 por
ciento del gas que se consume en
alemania es importado de rusia una
dependencia que ellos mismos han
prometido terminar escuchemos
todos los ministros del g7 han
coincidido en que se trata de un
incumplimiento unilateral de los
contratos vigentes han subrayado una vez
más que los contratos celebrados son
válidos y las empresas deben y tienen
que respetarlos
esto significa que un pago en rublos es
inaceptable y pedimos a las empresas
afectadas que no cumplan con la demanda
de putin projects listing
el propósito de estas sanciones siguen
las estimaciones sobre qué tanto se ha
impactado la economía rusa
esta vez el dato lo brinda s mpeg loval
que estimó o recortó su estimación de
crecimiento para el producto interno de
rusia según la agencia la economía rusa
sufrirá una contracción del 8.5 por
ciento este año mientras que polonia y
turquía perderán más de un punto
porcentual de su crecimiento es amp y
asegura que los países emergentes de
europa son los más expuestos a través de
los canales de comercio y financiación
también muchos importadores de energía
serán afectados por la subida de los
precios para polonia estima que la
inflación interanual será del 8,9 por
ciento en 2022 desde el 5,4 que ya
habían estimado anteriormente en su
pronóstico para turquía aseguran que el
aumento de los precios de los alimentos
la energía y el debilitamiento de su
moneda van a empeorar las perspectivas
de inflación que de por sí ya son
elevadas en parís hubo protestas por el
alto precio del combustible que pasó
allí decenas de conductores de uber y
choferes privados se manifestaron en
parís para exigir un aumento de sus
tarifas doctores denunciaron la falta de
ayudas ante la subida del precio del
combustible según ellos el presupuesto
de combustible aumentó en 450 euros en
el mes desde el inicio de la guerra en
ucrania y el precio internacional del
petróleo superó la barrera de los 100
dólares y el mercado se mantiene volátil
por el desarrollo de este conflicto en
europa jorge y terminemos con los
indicadores
empezamos con wall street que cerró en
positivo otra financiación marcada por
los altibajos y con preocupaciones en
torno a ucrania el commit 19 en china
las acciones europeas cerraron en
positivo liderada por los fabricantes de
automóviles y los sectores defensivos
que fueron motivados por un posible
acuerdo de paz entre rusia y ucrania
tiene américa latina' los mercados se
mueven en torno al conflicto en europa y
los resultados empresariales la bolsa de
sao paulo terminó sus rachas de siete
subidas y cayó levemente jorge gracias
por todos estos datos y a ustedes los
invitamos a que sigan con nosotros
[Música]
i